The Joe Rogan Experience did you see the
Mayweather Gotti thing yesterday
no I didn't so John Gotti the mobster
his okay the brawl yeah so what happened
was this is the end of the fight but if
you could see if you could find what
caused it because there's a there's a
video that shows the end of the fight
and in the end of the fight what
happened was if you just Google uh just
tweet like put Mayweather pack out in
Twitter but you'll find it uh excuse me
Mayweather Gotti what caused it he was
holding so he wouldn't stop oh boy who's
boxing him up yeah so Floyd is just
piecing him up so Floyd you know I mean
even at 46 he's the greatest of all time
and this kid is really an MMA fighter
he's a tough guy he caught Floyd a
couple times with some little shots but
most of the time mostly he's just
getting boxed up right
boxed up by literally the greatest boxer
of all time but he was holding on quite
a bit and wouldn't let go and was trying
to like hold and clinch and hit which is
something like right here which is
something you can do in MMA so he's
protecting himself from Floyd but he's
not letting go and so Kenny Bayless gets
tired of him not listening and not
letting go and he pushes him off and he
says that's it I'm stopping this fight
that's it you won't listen to me I am
calling this fight so he goes crazy and
gets away from Kenny Bayless and just
starts wailing punches at Floyd look at
this Floyd catches him on the counter
right there
knocked him way over there yeah well the
other guy got in the way too but you
know I mean it became a melee and so
then there's fights in the ring and then
there's fights outside the ring there's
all this cell phone footage of footage
of people brawling and sucker punching
each other I saw some of that that was
just crazy there's sometimes this beat a
um yeah here's the those brawls outside
everybody's right this random brawl just
people just screaming and yelling at
each other but at the end of the day
just
you know he was just getting frustrated
but before he was just boxing him up
which is what he does that's what you
you came into his sport yeah
got into his Arena you crawled into the
snake hole and then got mad the snake
will bite you
Yeah by me like that like you and my
yeah I don't know why he didn't listen
why he didn't let go I don't know if
they were talking [__] to each other I
don't know what was going on but Kenny
so that's it that's a wrap
and then everybody went crazy that's
crazy including him
he probably didn't expect that probably
thought maybe had they taken any well
there's no points right because it's an
exhibition so that's what's what's
interesting is Floyd's making more money
than anybody and he's boxing people who
have no chance of beating him and he's
doing it as an exhibition it doesn't
even hurt his record because of
the drug of boxing there's lots of money
just like the but I don't even think he
needs to he don't need any money he
spent so much money yeah yeah but he
don't need anything are you sure yeah
I'm Floyd good I bet he's if he's
playing for the future you got to keep
it coming in if you're going to keep
spending the way he spends yeah but I
think he has a lot of other business
interests that he can give money from
hopefully and not just boxing
but it's the it's the drug of getting
Floyd's still trained when he even when
he doesn't have a fight he posted this a
week ago of all of the Air Force Ones he
buys he only wears them once and then
gives them away to someone one fresh
pair a day come on man he needs that
money that money has to keep coming in
if you're gonna live like this it's not
that expensive though but it's only 46.
but he does this with everything man
he's got a million dollar watches I
don't think he buys every every pair
he'll give them to him yeah because
because then you get a video like that
right that's smart and then you get
Floyd's Air Force Ones giving away for
charity that's the tax write-off and all
sorts of things it goes yeah you got a
good point but those million dollar
watches they're not giving you those
they
they still you know
worth whatever they were like if you got
eight of them yeah
look at those diamonds
that's ridiculous
that's millions of dollars worth of
diamonds I mean that is because that's
Bonkers that's crazy yeah look at this
watch
yeah he's like a professional baller
like that that watch right there is not
like I wouldn't wear it because it's not
mine
thing yeah even if you know I had I
wouldn't wear it it's just not
attractive to me no I'm not into blinged
out watches either nah I like mechanical
watches like a metal yeah that's what I
like but you know I get it